hello everyone and welcome back to round
10 of the magnets Invitational we are
continuing with the match he core
Nakamura vs. Fabiano Caruana this is
game 2 and in game 1
Fabiana won after after a fairly long
struggle but in the end he prevailed and
now Nakamura needs a win to get back
into the match and he has the white
pieces so let's see let's see what he
decided to play yeah he went for d4 and
d5 by Fabi with c4 and now c6 is that
it's as if all the players agreed that
well made some sort of a gentlemen's
agreement that everyone has to go for
the Slav but okay we we haven't had the
Slav in quite quite some time Knight of
three Knight of 6 and now Queen to c2 we
have D captures on c4 we have Queen
captures and c4 recapturing in out
Bishop the f5 this is the most most
often played line g3 and now II 6 as the
Bishop has been developed with Bishop to
g2 by Nakamura and Bishop to e7
preparing the castle
we have castles by both sides and now
Queen to b3 putting pressure on the b7
pawn and the Fabi defends with Queen b6
and also offers a queen trade so Knight
B to d2 nakamora continuous development
he says ok if you trade I can recapture
with the knight and Bobby does the same
Knight B to d7 we had Knight to c4 now
attacking the Queen and now this is a
fairly often played line amongst the top
flares either Queen captures or Queen to
a6 are the main moves here Bobby decides
to move the Queen and now Bishop the f4
with ideas of trading of the dark square
Bishop with Bishop to d6 we have nice to
be 6 by Fabi with a double attack on the
night here and now Bishop to d6 as
planned so now the point is of course if
you go for the night and Bishop captures
comes with an attack on the rook and
once you move it you mess up the black's
pawn structure and white is of course
better so instead of Fabi goes rook ft 8
doesn't allow this capture to come with
an attack on the rook and now we have
night f2 d2 there is one game in the
database for Bishop captures and e7 was
played but here rook F to e 8
sorry night f.2d - now that is a new
move in the position so what what I
wanted to say is that some of you have
been asking me in the comments section
what is this whole new move thing
so basically when I say it is as a move
for tinder we have a completely new game
I'm using the website called three six
five chess comm there are a lot of
different websites that offer big chess
databases however this one is free and
I'm using this one now like for example
I tried using a one that's like $5.00 a
month and the difference between using
that one and the free one is that the
one that you pay will of course show you
more games that reach this position but
those will be even games between 700
players 2,000 players 2,200 players and
the free one only gives you top tier
games so like maybe maybe twenty four
fifty rating and above so as mostly
we're showing the games by by elite
players I decided to use that one so
that's what I mean when I say a new move
has been played but at night f2d - a new
move in the position and now rook a to
d8 with a double attack on the bishop
now so bush of character Sonny seven
rook captures and now III just defending
the d4 pawn we have Knight captures on
c4 Knight captures on c4 and now Bishop
to e4 Fabi and finds a way to trade off
everything we have rook F the c1
and now farm it just goes for the trade
bishop capture screen captures and
finally gets his c5 movie and point is
after white characters you can just
deliver check and the recapture the pawn
which is what Nakamura goes for we have
D captures on c5 Quincy six check King
moves and now re captures the pawn we
have Queen to a3 offering a queen trade
now and rook the season focuses okay but
I would like to have my rook on the C
file while we do that so a Nakamura
trade we have Queen captures rook
captures and now a nice little trick by
Nakamura saying the foggy that you have
some background issues Knight to d6
point is that of course after captures
captures which was played in the game
you cannot recapture story you cannot
capture here because of rooks
the eight and this will not result in to
checkmate after a black gives up all the
these pieces so if Abby realizes that
there are in fact some background issues
so he creates some room for a king we
have g5 and now rip the c8 and Gomorrah
forces a trade here with rook captures
Knight captures and now he will try to
use his knights to undermine these pawns
so a6 and Knight to d6 now we have b5 as
the b7 pawn is under attack and now
Knight the b7 we have King to f8 Bobby
now starts bringing his King into the
game but Knight the c5 now goes after
the a6 pawn we have a 5 now Knight the
b3 going after the a 5 points so a4 and
now nice to d4 going after the B 5
points so b4 by Fabi and now again
Knight to c6 going after the be four
pawns so now it's a question whether you
push a 3 or B 3 do you want to do you
want to trade you want to block the
position Bobby decides for a3 and of
course nakamora blocks that would be
three we have Knight to d5 now just
defending the pawn here and the problem
with the just kicking get away would
efore is that you can go Knight to c3
and then after captures you can just
grab the e4 pawn you can return to c3
and then you will put a lot of pressure
on the a 2 points so White's night will
be stuck here defending it so instead
nakamora finds a very nice idea f3 now
gives up the e3 pawn which fobby
captures and now only now he captures on
before so Knight the d1 nakamura Bobby
also once the now gets to the c3 squared
to put more pressure on the a2 pawn and
King to f1 by Nakamura we have Knight to
c3 and now pink T 1 we have King the e7
and now King 2 D 2 so as you can see
this this plan Fabi chose to hunted the
pawns with with the night sorry that
Nakamura chose allowed him to get this
point all the way here and now he will
try to undermine it with the with his
King and the knight of course
so Knight the b5 gets the knight out of
the way but King d3 we have E 5 and now
Knight the c2 so now put pressure and
the pawn here and the threat is of
course Kings before you click away the
night and you pick up the a3 pawn so
King is 6
by far by fabio and now kinked ac4 with
the idea that we mentioned 96 Czech and
now kink the c5 with h5 by Fabi he wants
to start of course pushing and create a
passed pawn of his own and Knight
characters on a3 and by doing this a
Nakamura is not only up a pond but he
has two connected passports on the Queen
side so g4 Fabi of course wants to
create some fast bones as well
so f captures with h captures in the now
night the c2 and here we are going to
have a race nakamura will be pushing on
the Queen side and Fabi on the Kings
side so f5 with and now before pushing
first night the e3 which is just a very
useful move as it prevents the black
from just continuing to push as you lose
the pawn here so first night the e4
check King to c6 and now Knight to f6
guarding the pawn here so you can now
start pushing but now who's faster well
we'll just have to we'll just have to
wait and see
with a four by Nakamura and now f4 by
Fabi and now not capturing but rather
Knight the f1 keeping an eye on the g3
pawn we have f3 now creating a passed
pawn and a5 now and here Knight to d5
and it's again a very a very fragile
position so there's only one move that
wins for Nakamura here so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
move while I give you a couple of
seconds to test your endgame skills of
course so for those of you that found
the correct idea congratulations on
being an excellent endgame player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
show it's not a six a six actually runs
into into a very devious drawing line
but I will show it as it's very
interesting a six now just night before
check King moves and now you pick up the
a6 pawn so sorry yeah okay you pick up
the a6 pawn King captures and now you go
to e4 and now the problem is after b4 it
seems like white is of course much
faster problem is king d5 you're gonna
put b5 King to d4 and now b6 runs into
III and here's a problem now you either
give up the night and then this pawn
will Queen but it will queen with chair
that's the problem and that's why black
is faster and on the other hand if you
go b7e too and don't move the don't move
the night then again he captures on f1
will again come with check and you will
be much faster b8 Queen and now this is
just winning you're gonna deliver check
and it doesn't matter where the white
king goes you're just gonna go check
King moves and now check on b1 and
that's the game you're just gonna
capture capture and of course with your
king being so so close to the white
pawns it's it's a very easy game to win
you're just gonna play f2 and that's
that's it and on the other hand if this
isn't winning maybe Kings to b7 is but
the problem is that if I've Eve or is
just just too strong for black so the
move that wins the game is king to c5
and this is what what Nakamura played
now far we continued with E for but
Nakamura knows that there's always time
to put the a poor king to D for now so
sometimes in order you know to really go
forward you have to go back so now that
there's a question of the e4 pawn
there's really not much you can do here
you cannot you cannot defend it because
then you lose the night and you have to
play something so king d6 but now King
captures on e4 we have King to c5 and
here Nakamura just played a6 and it was
in this position that Fabiano caruana
resigned the game and the game 2 goes to
Nakamura which means that he is back in
the match so very exciting stuff and
well extremely well played a end game by
Nakamura so here you resigned as there
is nothing you can do you cannot prevent
the a point while also keeping an eye on
your pawns here you might go Knight c7
but then just a 7 and after king b6 to
go after the pawn now you go King a4 and
you start you start gobbling up bones
King captures and a7 you're gonna go
captures here and after f2 it's not a
problem just h4 you push all these pawns
you're gonna capture this pawn as well
your bit you're you are up to 3 points
of course completely winning so after
this after this a6 move Fabi resigned
and a great victory for Hikaru Nakamura
who now equalizes the match yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoy it
I would like to thank Terence Nolan Jana
Raskin Steve Wacha
Thomas Connors and Rowland molar for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the magnets
and rotational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day